well if this makes you feel any better i
think this will actually make you feel
better
um yeah so uh day of the rake is
is um well i'll just play it
it's the teddy tower chronicles book of
thrones three it's so ridiculous
uh begin mobile weapons production if
anyone sees you you know what to do vox
they texted him yes dark lord so we're
i'm just telling you i'm very worried
[Music]
i believe he's moved out of his home and
he's living exclusively in the
wilderness now
he's gonna be using sticks oh he's
building things with them
i'll just shoot you
yeah if you see him
if he's right there where all i see is a
tree
he's the guy with the leaves tucked into
his belt
he's the he's the guy with all the
branches tucked into his old navy cargo
pants i only see
leaves where is he he's gone now
right there where right there he's
pointing a bow and arrow at us
by the way that [ __ ] shot the arrow
just went down
they just don't go anywhere
i like the karate bow karate you're
better off just throwing it
i've never been this far from
civilization before
another there's a highway right there
he's never been this far from
this playground the plague we've never
seen this far playground
find us all the way out here
[Music]
if anyone sees you you know what to do
the leaf in the hoodie is my favorite
tell the dark lord we're returning to
base
we need more berserker sauce what is
berserker sauce
it's like a hot sauce i think that what
it is explain some sort of hot sauce
is he doing product placement or like
some sort of sauce for pasta i think he
said
okay um zack wilds
stronger than death berserker hot sauce
there it is
uh mission complete good work vfm
was your position compromised yes
it's one of my favorite on the [ __ ]
it's it's
this is turning into an avengers
universe we got a nice beef going
it's gonna be bad starting off the year
with some good beef it's a good day of
the rake of course if you want to check
out his stuff